[Musique]
comme on peut l'entendre on est sûr sur
radio classique non pelées vaches toute
la journée ont la chance d'écouter les
plus grands compositeurs saônoise aubrac
island décosse vivent en harmonie bercé
par les notes des plus grandes pièces de
musique classique
aujourd'hui éric samson doit boucler un
veau né ce matin avec l'aide de ses
employés thomas et maxime octavia
rejoint officiellement le troupeau de
150 têtes
voilà c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
ben oui on se prend un joli contact
contre-feu l'un ancien cavalier
international eric s'est reconverti dans
l'élevage il y a quinze ans dans sa
ferme de 150 ha ha auffargis cohabitent
chevaux bovins poule et même des
abeilles
grâce à un partenariat avec un
hypermarché de rambouillet il élève
aussi des aurochs vaches préhistorique
quasiment disparu une passion des
animaux et de leur bien-être
la relation avec les avec les animaux
c'est primordial ils ont malheureusement
pour beaucoup des dix courtes mais je
veux leur assurer la meilleure vie
possible dans les meilleures conditions
à la maison avec this fait mieux en
termes de qualité nutritive en termes de
bien-être animal et ce jusqu'au bout je
milite je suis membre de la fad
l'association en faveur de l'abattage
des animaux dans la dignité
abattage sans souffrance et sans stress
foin à volonté et prairies sans
pesticides des terres sèches et sans vie
dans les années 90 en cause
l'utilisation massive de produits
chimiques
désormais elles servent à nourrir les
animaux de manière totalement naturelle
eric c'est sûr qu'elles sont prêtes pour
les beaux jours il y manque qui manque
un peu de traces dans cette parcelle
pour avoir avec laurent pour
réensemencer un petit peu on fait du sur
semi a jamais on retourne la terre ont
fait que du sur famille mais en mettra
un petit peu de trèfle violet trèfle
blanc je regarderai pour remettre
quelques légumineuses
plus on va mettre de variétés d'herbes
plus on va donner le goût à la viande un
savoir faire et une qualité qui ont
séduit les plus grands chefs du trianon
palace à versailles à l'abbaye des vaux
de cernay en passant par paris mais
fervent défenseur du local il veille
aussi à fournir les restaurateurs
voisins
deux en cuisine christophe cornier
maître restaurateur de l'auberge de
l'élan travail s'est produit depuis une
douzaine d'années
on a sympathisé on à échanger et puis
après voilà on a découvert ce qui arrive
faisait ses convictions voilà comme nous
si on est des gens de conviction donc le
courant est bien passé
des convictions qui eric souhaite
partager au plus grand nombre avec sa
ferme modèle il espère montrer qu'une
autre agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et des animaux est
possible notre business model il est
complètement abouti parce qu'on n'a pas
d'un prends parce que les bêtes sont
nourries uniquement au point et à
l'herbe
donc on n'a pas les dépenses que peuvent
avoir les structures classiques il ya
moyen de faire mieux avec des animaux en
meilleure santé avec des animaux qui
s'exprime avec vraiment du vivant en
redonnant du vivant la terre pour rendre
ses produits accessibles
eric a ouvert une boutique gourmande il
ya un an favoriser le local et la
qualité une tendance sociétale
selon une étude réalisée par
l'observatoire de la consommation
responsable
86% des français estiment que consommer
local est une priorité